hello everybody my name is markiplier
yeah shut up guy oh dude I'll get here
whoo-hoo keeping my arms and legs I need
to get out I need to get out of here
I've become the worst feeling that
someone something is following okay so
here's the deal
someone was very very very very very
very kind enough to make a map a
hand-drawn map of this entire place and
I've always felt that claustrophobia was
one of the coolest ones they made it was
just a very original concept so I got
the map up here so I'm gonna be looking
over a lot of the map so I actually know
what I'm doing okay I've got a route
planned out in my head this map is all
fing fog out number one okay now I got a
route planned out here I'm gonna cut
down straight down here and if I cut
over in this but I know that like Sunday
becomes way too aggressive after like
four or five or whatever it is so I got
like I gotta like booked it once I hit
five I should be around right around
here it was actually a good spawn point
you can actually get random spawn points
in the game I didn't know and I always
thought that the keys had random spawn
points I but I think it just seemed that
way because I was always so lost in the
maze and it didn't know where the hell I
was going so anyway on here and then
we're gonna go up and there's a statue
and obviously the statute was supposed
to be a point of reference but I
completely ignored that here that early
era that early our TVs there is he gonna
be there you gotta stay there
hello I know
hey cutter another Hey don't dictate a
doodoo dirtier okay so if I there's
another route no obviously it's a maze
so there are multiple points of entry Oh
God well good I'm gonna try to get like
seven and then go unless I get like
turned around which is highly probable I
mean it's always very very possible that
I will get turned around here for four
ten all like record time Oh like a balls
like oh come on out Slendy
I got your map by one with piece of
paper I picked up from you before so I
keep feeling like it's getting a bit
darker and it's not supposed to get dark
this early because if it gets dark that
means he's like right on your ass
and I don't want him to be on my ass
that's sounding weird but either way I
don't want him to be near me or my ass
also sounded weird again but yeah you
get one either
come on and debate huh he grew tentacles
he didn't have tentacles before but then
he grew them oh where am i where am i
where no this it does it does it does it
lose it is it is it time fine oh yeah oh
yeah
oh he gets way too aggressive after five
oh no I went in the baby burn oh this is
not part of my room it's not part of my
room
this is not where my root was supposed
to run but it's okay because I got it
right number seven like a mouse oh crap
where the hell am I going I don't even
know I don't even know where I'm going I
think if I go here I think I'm not sure
oh all right let me get the doors ah
crap ease on now right why why are you
doing fair I think I'm trying I'm trying
to get out of here but I'm saying stuck
director I'm like stuck ah that's right
get out of here I'll come where the hell
am I
I don't even know where I oh I see you
you can't get for me I see you okay my
go this way and then I
Oh through here and then not down okay
and if I cut across here I think I'll
get to where I need to be I'm in the
open I don't like being in the open god
oh god oh god dude right around this
corner is another key oh god he's gonna
activate mushroom trip mode yeah Oh what
no no I'm pressing why oh why oh what I
want to play mushroom trip mode
no no aah aah
in the game crashed oh that's bull honky
Oh Bo monkey okay fraction three two one
thing I think it did it did it there it
is okay it's gone oh man I had nine keys
nine oh if I hadn't got so turned around
at that last part that last word is
pretty confusing how did I get but I
mean the keys are the last three keys
are like right there in a row but most
doors are there too so I don't know I
need to get out of here I do need to get
out of here but worst feeling that
something something he's following me
following me oh man I just ran out of
sprint I spread it way too early I don't
need to sprint okay I'm in the same
spawn okay good because you can spawn in
all four corners of the map but if I'm
here then I just blend the same route
that I ruined before but now I know it a
little better because I actually am here
doing it and I don't need a sprint until
like five
once I have five then he kind of gets
all up in my grille and I don't let
nobody get all up in markiplier skrill
no I'm saying no okay alright let's just
get out of here let's just get what
we're getting and then get out of here I
kind of noticed that my voice one really
high pitch that last playthrough
perfectly normal
I'm a manly man nothing wrong with me
something wrong with you
who you talking about I'm perfectly
normal
it was a stressful situation I handled
it like a boss oh no need to sprint he's
probably not going in where he's in that
same place he was there before I know he
was cuz I was there when he was there
and I saw him and then I ran like a
little girl is he still there still cuz
I need to go this way I got her you
don't get easy yes his is exactly there
he likes that place I don't know why I
don't know why but I'm not gonna
question him if he wants to stand there
all damn day I am perfectly okay with
that you doing there's more than one
route I mean this maze like place it's
pretty easy to navigate when you need to
go to other places okay so
fourth key should be here and then
that's when things start to get a little
hairy all right all right like a shadow
in the night like a stealthy cat in an
alley like a ghost haunting a dark house
a closet even like like a black marker
writing on a black piece of paper like
dark gray on darker gray okay oh you're
there before any group technicals Hannah
so I just got to take my alternate route
seriously zealand does he have like set
spawn points I'm actually curious about
that because ah [ __ ] did that happen
before I think that happened before does
that happen I think that might happen I
should I should have remembered that oh
god where am I
I'll give it give it give me get me get
me get me get me get me get me [ __ ] yeah
oh no I'm not gonna back up shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
up shut [ __ ] Oh got him all on sprint to
sare I've completely sprinted out I am I
am an a-hole I am an angel all where am
I going oh god no I need ya right here
this is it this is it he's right any-any
okay okay he's done maybe that lost
seven like a palace Oh what you got some
Andy oh what's that oh yeah nothing oh
not nothing hello baby
so I go in the second in here and then I
just so calmly walk around here and then
go down here right around this corner
and then the key will be over here in
the head for the doors I spray for the
freaking doors that's what I do to screw
everything else I'm going for the doors
I don't need more than eight because it
said eight plus activate mushroom mode
and I don't care about dam dong thing as
opposed to the I'm going around where
the fudge am I going I don't even know I
don't I do not know where I am going I
don't know unless print cuz that's what
I do
oh nice gather gather coming don't be
knock play play play play
gosh yes yes yes oh it worked
Oh what I no way where am i where am i
how did I get why did I take those
shrooms I can't remember okay wasn't
blacked out I need to get out of here
yeah I have the worst feeling that yeah
something is following me took some bad
shrimp Oh what the hell oh my whoa geez
all right this is Technicolor madness oh
my god my eyes are hurting there's like
killing my eyeballs I spawned in the
same place like again so number one oh
god I can't I can't even look at this
oh god my eyes are like about to explode
Oh God and seriously my camera is I'm
not doing anything my camera is just
kind of oh well I wonder if slender's
different I'm just gonna I spawned in
the same place I'm gonna run the same
route I mean supposedly useful spawn and
random points but it either I'm really
lucky or this is just working out in my
favor
goodlet - oh God the colors the color
triggers Oh God Oh
okay um if I go this way then I am yes
this way it's Oh God
lady you were it was like 8-bit or no
16-bit color oh he's right there same
place but nothing seemed different about
him
I'm gonna let him get me in a bit just
cuz I can't stare at this Technicolor
Madness forever
uh-huh oh god my eyes are about to
explode out of my skull no wait that's
wrong no that's right that's right
that's right
uh I'm going the right way Oh God
I wonder what would happen if you
complete the game with mushroom trip
mode I don't know I'm gonna try I
suppose cuz why not
God just buy eyeballs are about to burst
out of my skull Oh God
I was hoping that there would be like
some funky music like wow
wrong roll some weird sax going on in
the background
oh okay so um if I go this way
yeah this is it that's this man I guess
it might be quicker if I go another way
from this
I don't know target oh I get turned
around enough I better just stick with
what I know although I think I'm
forgetting most of my childhood by
living in Oz oh that's wrong Oh God
seriously I think this is like
subliminal messaging into my brain to
delete all of my memories so Oh God
okay so if I go over here and then here
hi hey buddy
oh he's gone what really just like that
I put him behind a pillar for two
seconds and he disappeared okay then
here's number five Oh God God a good
golly I think you only need to get eight
keys to win the game I think maybe keys
you have a really good chance of winning
on out to the door t that this flame
would be quicker yep
this way is quicker because the other
way would take you through the
loop-de-loops oh goodness
okay seven of eight right here like a
box I'm getting good at this this would
be helpful I still need to beat a game
hahahaha disappeared
second one good got dark oh god is there
a way that this is like somehow
injecting drugs into my brain
oh no wait this is yeah is it is it Bank
bump okay
now I go for the exit I think actually
if I go right here I can get number nine
like number nine is right here big look
oh yeah oh yeah
we get 10 oh no I can't get 10 I went
the wrong way
watch alright that's it for now that was
fun while it lasted
man oh god my eyes though I'm still
seeing the walls are like multicolored
when I'm looking around my room Oh God
so thank you all so much watching thank
you I don't recall your name
I would I would thank you in person but
the person who made this map for me not
the makers of the map them the guide map
to help me beat this right in the
comments I'll try to thumb you up and so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotations for more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye